here's what drives the driver
in the states that are affected here's
what
you can do you're the driver don't panic
oh my god it's it's like do you laugh or
you cry why exactly is the biden
administration reversing itself
on whether you can unmask the answer is
because they have to distract from the
crappiest news cycle
that they have had really since biden's
inauguration so biden has been treated
to
just sycophantic drooling media coverage
since his inauguration and then this
week inflation hit
the border crisis continues to to
marinate we've got war in the middle
east
and all this is happening on the back of
a horrible employment report
so that's a really bad week for this
administration so now it's time
inject some optimism by you know
actually saying the true thing that we
should have said three months ago
okay so over at the border migrant
children apparently are still being
stuck overnight on buses according to
nbc news
in a vast parking lot outside the kay
bailey hutchinson convention center
miners who migrated to the us without
their parents are waiting on buses to be
sent to live with relatives or sponsors
staying overnight eating and using all
the bathroom all within the confines of
the bus according to the owner of one of
the bus companies and advocates for the
children
in at least one case described to nbc
news a family says their 15 year old son
waited on buses from saturday to
wednesday
before beginning the long journey from
dallas to seattle
i mean so disaster area there's still
thousands of kids who are being held
in close quarters in the middle of uh of
apparently
you know the covered pandemic still
applies to migrants the good news is
that the dhs secretary apparently has
short-term memory loss he says he
doesn't remember saying
that migrants should come he did
he said i'm not saying migrants
shouldn't come i'm just saying they
shouldn't come right now
he was reminded of this and alejandro
marcus was like i don't remember saying
that
me who what you remember saying don't
you that
we're not telling you not to come those
are your words that you said in a press
conference
you you said that right i don't i don't
recall saying that i don't believe you
don't recall saying that
that's correct senator i have never said
we'd be happy to refresh your memory for
you and some questions for the right i'm
sure that that is
interesting news that i'm sure everyone
will the secretary has just said he he
doesn't have any memory
of making those comments that's
extraordinary senator
i have never said that the border is
open
okay nobody said he said the board is
open you just said i'm not saying don't
come
i'm just saying don't come right now
that's what mayorka said but he doesn't
remember it so that's good
meanwhile by the way the biden
administration will resume construction
of southern border wall levy
according to fox news the u.s army corps
of engineers will restart construction
on a 13.4 mile stretch of levy in the
rio grande valley the decision
reportedly follows pressure from local
residents and politicians to mend
the incessant crossing surge priority
repairs are set to begin in six weeks to
prevent flooding followed by the
establishment of a concrete levee wall
fit with safety barriers in six
to nine months so yeah they're shoring
up the wall that that's apparently a
super bad wall weird so they've replaced
they've sort of reversed themselves on
that
meanwhile inflation is here according to
the new york times the central fact of
the american economy in mid-2021
is the demand for all sorts of goods and
services has surged but supplies are
coming back slowly with the economy
acting like a creaky machine that was
turned off for a year and has some rusty
parts
well actually the economy is acting like
you would expect it to act when you pay
people to stay home
and when you tell them it's unsafe to go
back to work the good news is that the
biden administration has no idea what to
do with inflation i mean no clue so jen
sack he's like you know the inflation is
just a sign that everything is going
great
okay then crazy lady let's go with that
we've seen um over the last couple of
days to your point
some reaction to the cpi numbers that
came out
just yesterday and you know our view on
that is it reflects the reality of an
economy that's rapidly
turning back on because of a successful
economic strategy and if you dig into
the data
there are a couple of factors at play
that i think people are
taking a look at now that we've dug into
the data more okay yeah the factors of
play
are that everybody had more savings at
the end of last year than they had at
the beginning of last year because the
government paid them because they had to
pay them to stay home
and then you just continued pumping
money into their pockets and then you
said
you don't ever have to go back to work
basically because we'll pay unemployment
benefits all the way through september
meanwhile elizabeth warren and the left
wing of the democratic party who really
rule the roost
they're saying yeah i'm delighted that
biden is governing like a radical
are you surprised at how progressive the
policies are
they're being proposed by the president
oh not surprised delighted
this is the good news you know this is
one of the best things i talk about this
in the book
putting out plans means they're there
for everybody
and they're there for us to share and
improve on and make
better but this seems like big
structural change and i'm sorry
nobody expected that from him well all i
can say is
he ran on the most progressive agenda
in decades okay some of us pointed this
out at the time but we were being gasled
by the media that proclaimed that joe
biden was moderate here's the problem
all of this is starting to bear some
really really ugly fruit you've got the
inflation you got the unemployment
numbers they're not great
and then you had people waiting in gas
lines by the way it turns out the
colonial pipeline just paid a five
million dollar
ransom to the hackers who hacked the
pipeline
which of course is going to incentivize
more people to hack pipelines when you
pay ransoms like this this is where the
us government really should have stepped
in and done something but
they didn't so i mean did the government
assure colonial pipeline that it would
backfill them if they paid the ransom
how exactly did this work
when bloomberg news asked joe biden if
he was briefed on the company's ransom
payment the president paused and then
said
i have no comment on that okay so
all of this is going really well plus
joe biden continues to be an utterly
incoherent
boob i mean he just joe biden's war with
the teleprompter continues basically
it's now it's now rocky it's like joe
biden
is apollo creed and the teleprompter is
rocky and they just
keep having these repeat battles every
day i expect any moment that the
teleprompter is going to run
up the stairs of the philadelphia museum
of art and throw
its non-arms in the air because like the
continuing battle between joe biden and
the teleprompter is one of the most
fascinating battles in american public
life
i can't wait for for joe biden versus
the teleprompter part three when mr t
comes in he's like i pity the fool can't
read a telepr anyway
here is here is joe biden battling the
teleprompter
the rule is very simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do
it's vac said or masked
get vaccinated it's vac said or masked
it sounds like mike myers and so i
married an axe murderer
on love ed unvax
ed hey what in the what in the actual
okay
and then that was that was the the first
joe biden versus the teleprompter
uh in that one they fought to a draw in
joe biden versus the teleprompter too
the teleprompter comes with a clear
knockout
now here's what drives the driver
in the states that are affected here's
it that you can do
the drivers don't panic number one
[Laughter]
oh my god it's like i don't know do you
laugh or you cry
i mean really solid stuff there from
from the teleprompter teleprompter
comes with a clear victory right there
that's a tko in like round two
by the teleprompter i i need that again
was that in english play it again now
here's what drives the driver
in the states that are affected here's
it that you can do
the drivers don't panic number one
here's what drivers should do
here's what drives the drivers in the
drive droovy in the ryan gosling movie
drive
drivers drive drewbin tran jupiter
red jupiter yeah everything is going
fantastically so is it any wonder that
the cdc reversed itself yesterday
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video